foreign
[Music]
for forcing my son to call me Mom
oh here's a good one okay
this is a meaty one when my husband and
I wanted a child we decided to pursue
surrogacy instead of a traditional
pregnancy it was a hard decision that
took a lot of late night talks and
fighting because he wanted to be
involved in the pregnancy and everything
but I was terrified of PPD postpartum
depression the postpartum body and all
the morning sickness that came with it
finally we went through an agency to
find a suitable gestational carrier
otherwise known as a human being I'd
like to think we were pretty involved
throughout the pregnancy process and we
somewhat befriended the carrier
befriended the carrier
um nowadays we're not closed by any
means but we send each other birthday
and holiday wishes and such
hey my son found out about the surrogacy
it wasn't really a secret by any means
but the topic just never came up he was
talking about how he learned about it in
biology how I thought it was weird I
told him no it's completely normal and
that he came from a surrogate I didn't
think it would be that big of a deal but
for the next few days he started
pestering me about the details of who
the surrogate was and why I went through
with it well I told him my reasons and
he took from the conversation that I was
too lazy to have him myself
yes he's now insisting that I'm not his
mom
my husband told me that it's just a
phase that's probably because our son's
a little raw from an unrelated argument
we had earlier this month however I'm
honestly really hurt and disrespected
that he doesn't think of me as his mom
when I tried to have a discussion about
it he escalated after and now only calls
me by my real name instead of mom his
argument that is that it's his choice to
decide who he wants to call his parents
I kind of like this kid I gotta be
honest with you uh no I mean you're not
an a-hole for for forcing your son to
call you mom
um but you are the a-hole for choosing
surrogacy in the first place so that's
where you went wrong
you rented out a womb like you're
renting a room you know you treated
another person's body like a like an
Airbnb
and yeah they they volunteered for it I
mean they they like sold
their body to you literally I mean they
sold their womb to you and because you
didn't want to deal with the physical
changes that come with motherhood
um you're right your son was exactly
correct in fact you shouldn't talk to
his mom that way uh but but he's right
that you were just too lazy to carry the
child yourself now you're reaping some
of the consequences that your child
doesn't feel connected to you in the
same way because he's not now this is
different from something like adoption
where you're giving up comfort for the
sake of the child you're bringing the
child into your family but surrogacy is
is the opposite
because rather than being born from
sacrifice it comes from an unwillingness
to make a sacrifice
so I think it's a
I think it's a horrific practice
honestly and dehumanizing even the way
you refer to this but the carrier we
befriended the carrier
um it's terrible and you're Dale
[Music]
let's see my daughter came out as
transgender a few years ago and for her
birthday this year we legally changed
her first name to a feminine name of her
choosing my wife and I have always
supported her and her transition but my
daughter seemed disappointed that her
surname wasn't also changed
I am Icelandic American
um if you don't know surnames are quite
different than in other countries one
surname is their father's first name and
a suffix related to their gender
the son of jokool would be jokel's son
and the daughter of jokel would be jokel
doter
when my American wife and I married she
took my last name per American custom
and gave that same masculine surname to
our daughter which she was born all of
us have the same masculine last name my
daughter wishes to change her surname to
Joko doter in order to align with her
gender expression as well as Icelandic
naming Customs I hadn't considered this
for her as we live in the United States
and use the local Customs my wife and I
are on the fence about changing her
legal name again as processes like this
are very expensive and time consuming I
told her that her mother and I would be
more than happy to help with the
paperwork if she paid for the processing
my daughter doesn't accept our reasoning
and claims that we're only contributing
to her existing dysphoria by not going
through the process again so are am I
the also for making my transgender
daughter pay for her own surname change
but no absolutely not you are not the
[ __ ] for that
you are the [ __ ] for everything else
in this story
starting with the fact that you were
supportive
of your son pretending to be a girl
so your son and did you say how old your
son is uh 17. okay
uh your son has two problems here and
this is your son we're dealing with
your son is a self-entitled narcissist
demanding you have to pay for everything
or my dysphoria is going to be worse
this is emotional blackmail
um and this is in in gender ideology
it's very common this is one of you know
the the propagandists that that voice
this stuff on kids they encourage this
kind of emotional blackmail oh to get
everything you want just tell your loved
ones that you know you're gonna you're
that uh you're gonna have this dysphoria
and you'll be in emotional pain if they
don't do literally everything you want
so this is self-entitled narcissism and
it's also you know a certain element of
of you know just sincere confusion as
well
and you as the the parent as the adult
you're supposed to be a voice of reason
you're supposed to be a clarifying
presence
and by supporting your son in his
delusions his narcissism his confusion
uh you are dooming him to a life of
Despair and that's what makes you insult
[Music]
am I difficult for wanting my son to get
along with my boyfriend Sean is my 13
year old child and I am a single mother
Connor my current boyfriend of course
his name is Connor and I have been
together for two years Sean has disliked
Conor for as long as you can remember he
would go upstairs and ignore Conor
whenever he came to my place even though
I let Connor drop Sean off at school
Sean has never once expressed
appreciation or bonded with Connor
Connor pretended to be unconcerned by
his actions but I could tell he was hurt
by all of it I asked him why he despised
Conor so much he gave a list of various
reasons some of which I seriously doubt
to begin with he claims that when Conor
dropped him off at school a couple of
times he made derogatory remarks about
his Asian friends calling him a little
kung pao chicken
Etc
it's not it's not funny Sean mentioned
the time Conor didn't give his uh guinea
pig water and uh when he and I were at
the beach a year ago he was house
sitting for three days Sean also
mentioned how Connor advised him to man
up in a number of circumstances I
basically told him straight up that I
don't believe anything he's saying I
confronted Conor after that he denied
all of it so because Sean lied I took
away his gaming consoles as punishment I
also lectured him about abusing Conor
who might be his new stepdad one day
Sean told his father my ex what had
happened now my ex is cursing at me for
being unfair towards my son am I the
okay yeah you're the a-hole look I I
don't know your situation I I don't know
why you aren't married to Sean's dad but
what I do know is that what Sean wants
what all kids want is for their parents
to live together in the same house and
have a real intact family like their
real parents both of them like that's
that's what Sean wants that's what your
kid wants and like if you can't handle
that grow the hell up and if they can't
have that for whatever reason you can't
blame them for being upset
or for not being especially fond of the
the runner-up prize
hey Sean uh your dad and I you know you
can't have a real dad but here's Connor
I'll just settle on that instead and
besides
he's just your boyfriend
so Sean doesn't know if this guy will be
actually a permanent fixture in your
life have you thought about that
how many let me ask you how many
boyfriends have you had
since
the father of your child
I'm guessing more than one
so how many times has Sean been expected
to develop a father-son relationship
with the new guy in your life who just
ends up getting you know ends up out of
the picture in a year or two anyway you
might have your hands full once I'll
pick up the control though Mira thought
about the fact that that there's this
continual
effect of Abandonment that your son is
going through and so now he's putting up
defense defenses against that because
he's tired of being abandoned
by one man after another
whether it's the man's fault or yours or
a combination probably a combination
have you thought about that here at the
daily wire we are committed to winning
back the culture losing is just not an
option you know that about us there's
too much riding on it and part of that
means supporting businesses whose values
align with our own which is why I'm very
excited to tell you that we've teamed up
with Black Rifle Coffee Company many of
you know about Black Rifle already it's
a veteran founded and operated Coffee
Company who have made it their mission
to hire 10 000 veterans and they're well
on their way one of the many laudable
things Black Rifle does is help service
members successfully transition from the
military into entrepreneurship and
they're constantly giving back to
veteran foundations as well as law
enforcement and First Responders by
purchasing for Black Rifle Coffee
Company you're directly supporting the
military service Community what about
the coffee itself well it's bold it's
strong and it's really good Black Rifle
is very selective about where they
Source their coffee beans from and
they're disciplined when it comes to
ensuring the freshness of every bag so
go to blackriflecoffee.com use promo
code Walsh for 10 off your first order
or when you sign up for a new coffee
Club subscription the subscription gives
you free shipping on all coffee Club
orders Early Access to Club deals and
promotions and special discounts from
their partner Brands that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code walls
for 10 off your first order or when you
sign up to become a coffee Club member
Black Rifle coffee supporting veterans
and America's coffee
[Music]
[Music]